day eight and the almost paralysis of
daily life continues protesters are
still on the streets of the Lebanese
capital Beirut and other cities across
the country the country is at a
standstill as the protest movement
enters its second week schools
universities and banks remain closed
they are keeping up the pressure on the
government to resign the president
Michelin who the protesters also want
removed from office addressed the nation
for the first time since the crisis
began he presented his solution by
promising to fight corruption and
invited the protesters to engage in
dialogue the regime cannot be toppled
from the streets the regime must be
changed through conditional tools now we
have economic models to bring jobs we
also have concerns about the economy I
am willing to listen to your demands I
am waiting for you his invitation was
swiftly rejected civil society activists
say the people have heard promises like
these before the President's speech did
not address he had promises that he will
address corruption and try to return
some of the stolen money but that's just
promises that there is no confidence
with the people that they will actually
that the government will follow through
and recover the stolen money they say
they want radical change they want new
faces in power who are not affiliated
with the governing parties and they're
promising to keep Lebanon on lockdown
until that happens blocking the roads is
very essential because we have to keep
the country as paralyzed as possible of
course everything related to food water
transport and main the people who can't
afford maybe that you need me to eat we
need to drink the governing coalition
says the protest is only worsening the
economic crisis they're also accusing
opposition politicians of riding the
wave of popular anger to push their own
political agenda the governing coalition
choosing to resign and ignoring calls
for early elections their messages
change can only happen at the ballot box
at the appointed time both sides are not
budging this stalemate is dangerous in a
deeply divided society so far the Army
has not taken aside it hasn't used
excessive force to open roads
it hasn't emptied squares it has kept
the anti-government demonstrators and
loyalists apart
there have been counter protest by
supporters of political parties in power
so far they've been spontaneous and
limited in numbers that can change
Zeneca dare al jazeera Beirut